all right so all of this stuff so so
Trump yeah you're laying out a decent
case of putting all this stuff together
but let's talk quickly about the the
pushback from the establishment because
I think that's a an underreported piece
about this that the establishment has
tried very hard to push back on this and
they're rolling out Mitt Romney's lost
guy who lost last time is being
separated right um you roll out you know
Lindsey Graham goes from failed
candidate he endorses another failed
candidate another like they just roll
out the same guys and then if you watch
the debate and I've watched 90% of them
Trump systematically whether you agree
with him or not systematically destroys
these people I mean he embarrassed
Jordan I mean yeah she's worse than I am
system systematically destroys these
people I mean here he seems to have no
particularly consistent approach to
destroying them he just rocks up cracks
a few jokes and tells that tells it how
it is it's actually unsystematic which
is even more of an indictment on the
establishment how dumb they are how
stupid they are they think we're also
their thing where it is thing really is
so do you think if they had put if the
establishment had found someone that
basically knew who he was had decent
conservative principles so it's not I
guess the closest to that could have
possibly been Jeb but the bush name was
so damaging and he was also a terrible
candidate now he's a classic kook yeah
he's saying right as we say on the
internal [ __ ] why don't you define cut
because I see this popping up on well so
I like this word and all the rest of the
conservative media don't because they
know it describes them and it is well so
I know that you probably don't watch any
pornography anymore because since you've
been with your partner for so long to
get over their life clearly have sex
anymore like it's more like a lesbian go
ahead just just sexless we're sex I
missing you about carpet well I'm about
to talk about honest well okay so if you
were a porn viewer yes I'm not
particularly important view yeah if you
were a pawn viewer yeah um he didn't
like that early herbs a flipper aback
for sure to double down on that yeah um
if you were a porn viewer you may have
be familiar with the genre of porn in
which sort of white husband watches his
wife get rammed by a large black man now
it's always a large black man that
sometimes others whatever it's this is
this is cockiness is cuckoldry you know
from Shakespeare and
and and they think Chaucer to where and
it wasn't anything to do with race
anything is specifically do with race
it's just sort of become a bit of a porn
forum as well anyway the idea is it's
sort of it's people who have sold out
and enjoying watching their wife their
country their people they're supposed to
look after where there is readers in the
case of journalists or its constituents
the case of politicians getting [ __ ]
by some scary external force whether
it's radical Islam or mass immigration
or whatever now it's metaphoric it's a
metaphor you know and it's a perfectly
good and perfectly fun vibrant sort of
metaphor I quite like it and I use it
myself I think it's fun and it's it's
very it's vivid of course conservatives
now a conservative establishment which
has basically gone along with all of the
tenets of the left's and now looks to
the left for approval you know is it
okay can I say this is this racist is
this sexist then the the right the
right-wing establishments so terrified
of being seen as racist that they sort
of distance themselves from this word in
case there are any racial connotations
whatsoever no no we can't go against de
jure anyway Jabar Zippity is a perfect
example of this you know somebody who
who is weak who is there's no sense with
with Jeb Bush there was never any sense
and I feel that sorry he's gone now
because you can see the Conroy's guy but
there's no sense he would ever stick up
for his country and the one thing you
can't say about Trump is that he
wouldn't stick up for America now you
may disagree with some of his
prescriptions but he clearly loves the
country he clearly wants America to be
great again now that's a very
provocative slogan you know make America
great again
you know the again has it you've again
recognize that something was lost right
as a very desert there's a big there's a
big and shocking claim in there one that
politicians don't normally make that the
country is not great it's in fact is the
sort of thing you normally hear from
liberals
if we're honest you know Obama clearly
doesn't like this country very much but
you don't normally hear it from
conservatives now there's something very
exciting going on with that right with
it with this candidate something very
going be exciting all that terrifies the
establishment with what it what I've
what I've realized which i think is
really interesting is that that Trump
has Illustrated that the concerns of the
elites the concerns of the establishment
the concerns of journalists and
politicians and the people who run our
lives are so alien from what
ordinary people care about that they
can't even argue against him and it
resonate with the public I mean let's
take for example something that you and
I both care about the First Amendment
free speech freedom of the press Trump
has repeatedly suggested that he would
like to in some way qatal curtail the
full freedoms of the press he would like
just this week with The Washington Post
that he would like it he would like to
make it more I mean I think what he's
saying is he wants to strengthen
defamation law right bad news
particularly for you even more than me
right well is it because I don't lie
about people I might say funny names
sometimes I might really kill people but
I don't lie about them like the liberal
press does every day and the
conservative press is just as bad
frankly they're all terrible
I don't libel people I don't make up
facts about people why would I worry
about that I mean let's and let's look
at it from electoral point of view right
the public my head just went through
like the list of all my liberal friends
that like on stantly publicly and that
would suffer from this yeah right
exactly but I wouldn't yeah I've never
loved extras I've never I mean I say the
most appalling things about people but
they're true and I've never been sued I
miley innopolis have never been sued I
mean you would imagine I'll be in court
every week you know no I don't get sued
also because there's a difference
between satire you know jokingly but my
fact I get my facts right
I know oh there there are people who are
in court every week and it's Galka you
know because they they are so completely
unethical I mean I so that's why the
right felt that the Gawker thing with
Hogan I know we're jumping all over this
that's why the right was we enjoyed that
right really loved it but I saw it as a
huge victory too because we had places
like Walker that are just that are
literally trying to destroy lives mm-hm
it's enough yeah and I know they out
rate out private citizens yeah anyway so
I mean look the prop that probably get
overturned on appeal and it's probably
better that we don't have an anti free
speech precedent of quite that nature
because who knows what kinds of sex
tapes might be in the public interest in
future two things is you know Pinellas
County Florida juries don't set legal
precedent and it's gonna get overturned
right so it'll be a pn anyway see on the
Trump thing when he says that the press
are the bad guys most people agree with
him and this is what the press doesn't
understand because they genuinely
believe that they are like some sort of
like true you know worry
for truth and justice they're not
they're the bad guys the media in this
country there's been a systemic
industry-wide failure to tell the truth
in this country well it's the normal
situation on which the government steps
it and that's what we do in its oil
that's what we do when it's some other
kind of industry when there is a
system-wide failure in an industry
banking for instance the government
steps in and you know there's no reason
why the First Amendment should insulate
you from the consequences of your
actions if you go out and deliberately
mendacious lis knowingly
lie about people the keyword is
knowingly if you knowing that now the
libel standard in this country
flipper e slope though right I would say
the guy not the guy who gets offended by
megan kelly every other day god only
knows what he might think she's I think
she's a hell of a lot more triggered by
him than he is by her well that may be
but he's on his way to becoming the most
powerful man on earth and she's just a
reporter so I get what you're saying
that if she's telling the truth then
fine but what I would she's telling the
truth is just worrying when you have the
most offend you know this guy who loves
giving offense but at the same time he's
incredibly thin-skinned I don't think
he's splitting in libel laws he's not
fenced I know the president can't do
that in he's not he's not thin-skinned
at all he is making this very smart game
where he is illustrating the absurdities
of you know of offense taking an offense
culture it took the thing is you got
understand about Trump he didn't even
become a billionaire by accident he's
one of the smartest people in the
country you know he's so clever
everything he does is calculated
everything he does is designed to create
a particular effect a design to to reach
a certain goal so he even uses
bankruptcy to his advantage I guess we
put one who wouldn't I mean you know
that's liberal stuff to do this [ __ ]
you know of course of course you did it
was a businessman of course he donated
to Hillary so would I know if I was
running a business and there was a
strategic advantage of course I go to
her wedding I'd have her at my wedding
or whatever which I probably was best
moment in the first debate when he
admitted it is of course you would
it's so dumb to just otherwise the
reason it offends people so much or the
reason it surprised we were so much as
most politicians have never done
anything other than politics so if they
cozy up to a liberal it looks like
treachery or it looks like inconsistency
it looks like ideological kind of
tomfoolery well Trump isn't never been
in that position he was a businessman of
course he did these things but I want to
just yeah I finish on the press thing
when Trump says the press the bad guys
and he does it in speeches all the time
it gets some of the biggest cheers of
of his stuff right when he says you know
the press will never cover you
the press will never turn around and
show these huge crowds all they'll do is
if there's a protest they'll go down
there's a protester guys are losers
they're losers
they get some of the big those lines got
some of the biggest applause it's the
country hates the press and when the
press is like pull clutching about you
know Oh First Amendment or freedom while
you misused those freedoms you abuse
those freedoms you started lying about
men lying about race lying about
immigration lying about Islam lying
about everything that matters the press
has lied systematically to everyone
about everything every day all the time
for decades it has abused its privileges
and you know frankly I'm with Trump and
with and with the most with most
Americans the press is part of the
problem and for them to see no stop poll
clutching about the First Amendment well
you know what tough you abuse this for
decades okay so when you take the power
that the press has a lot of power you
take the power that the establishment
has on both sides a lot of power
Democrats Republicans right you add all
that up and now we still don't have an
election till November right we're in
the end of March here can this thing go
forward without getting much more
violent that's sort of where I see this
all going and by the way I'll be very
clear and say that I don't know which
way the violence is going to come from
I'm not going to say well I think we
violence is going to just all know which
way the gun violence is gonna come from
so I mean I don't think you should be
such a weasel I think you should say
what you think and I think I think you
probably agree with me well I use the
violence is gonna come from the left
just say it if obviously it's gonna come
for the less goes on a class matter is
gonna come from people protesting job
it's not going to come from Trump
protesters well look in the beginning of
the shift and just pick just because his
his chief of staff grab you know I has
it can be a bit grabby well of course he
is the guy that a Trump is that Trump is
it so and so much risk of being shot
unlike anybody else if there's somebody
that's gonna get assassinated in this
country its Trump is it any wonder the
people close to him a little bit
cautious and we get too much into that
because it involves you know other
people I used to work with but yeah but
you know if there's going to be violence
on the streets it is not going to come
fracture I'll be the Bernie people I get
that and that's not what that's I write
you know I tweeted the other day I like
Bernie more than I like his supporters
which is real
how I feel because yes I do agree if he
goes out they will have been yeah I know
you're right but I just let as a human I
think he's a decent human being whether
I agree with his power why I just
somebody somebody makes his people rock
that was up to some of the worst regimes
the world somebody wants to wants to
Institute so it's to socialism which
will make poor people poorer somebody
who wants to you know it somebody
believes in the lies that that feminist
activists tell about we don't have to
make this about him now no no no I mean
don't just throw this stuff out would
you really mean that
do you mean that you think he's a nice
person I think he's a nice person
everything everything he believed I
don't society more hateful a more
unequal I think that why do you say is a
nice in what he thinks the solutions so
you don't believe in any of his policies
but you think is a nice person I think
sometimes you can be a decent person who
and behind be wrong about everything in
policies what you're decent person
you're wrong about loss of it all that
so the widening is the reason I do agree
that the the violence will I don't know
Joe Matthews real close because
somebody's old and left-wing that
they're nice we don't do that with
right-wingers why did we automatically
assume just because I'm old and doddery
and he's got white hair and he sounds
like a crazy old lunatic oh he must be a
nice guy but I think really I see a nice
guy no he wants socialism in America
that's poisonous I think I can arrest
someone political philosophy that has
made people suffer everywhere it has
ever been tried I'm not everywhere
socialism has been it's my limitations
main people suffer that's right why I'm
not I think Bernie Sanders is nice I
don't forget it I think he was he ever
don't indicated is a decent noise I
could see id I've never seen any
underpinnings of the ideas that he talks
about of trying to make things more
equal on trying to change the system
which is the exact same stuff the
feeling more Dana Roberts the video but
that you like the channelings wait but
you're telling me that that the Trump
probably also revolution that is a
little something to do with the feeling
right but but I don't want to get
totally sidetracked on that what it's
not it's not a feelings not about
feelings well it has something to do
with feelings you're telling me all
these people and I'm agreeing with you I
know cultural libertarianism is not
about feelings cultural libertarianism
is a response to feelings over fact in
fact the defining characteristic of
cultural libertarianism is rigorous
adherence to evidence-based policymaking
and evidence-based beliefs and N and a
a rigorous insistence on classical
liberalism is got very little to do with
feelings girls do thumb because it's
often dressed up in a mischievous
package but cultural aboot Arianism is a
reaction against the feelings based
arguments of the left the feelings makes
arguments of the left as perfectly done
fiber Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders is
the apotheosis of everything you hate
but you're still feel the need to call
him a nice guy because he's old
alright so without getting into a Bernie
offshoot here we're probably a little
late for that I will grant you that if
Bernie goes down and the narrative just
continues yes it will be his people I
think that will be violent right yeah
the media then will try to blame it on
the Trump even that doesn't mean that
there are no Trump people that are
violent services even conservatives are
blaming it on Trump I mean was it Cruz
goes on TV the next after whatever
saying Trump is responsible for the
violence are they insane okay so do they
not realize why people are voting for
this guy they vote they're voting for
this guy because you lie like that yeah
it's it's astonishing okay so at the top
of the show what I mentioned was that
just this week Trump was giving a speech
in Arizona and these protesters block
the road these are not people they think
they're doing something good or there's
doing something to stop Trump but it but
they're all there some of them the rest
is just taking a paycheck for look could
whatever it is but they think that
they're stopping Trump somehow or
stopping him from being hurt or gonna
stop his movement but I think all
they're doing is strengthening him
because they need to have the best of
ideas because then people turn out there
more look what these people are doing
they're more these guys protest daddy
the more they show up and they're
violent it's just like my toxicologists
you know there's these feminists smear
blood on themselves
relevé lock all the stuff everybody saw
the video you know everybody saw and
everybody thought the same thing God my
I must have a point that's what they
thought and everybody thinks the same
thing when you know when these Britney's
protester show up for Trump and they are
the hateful angry violent divisive
people and everybody there for Trump is
like laughing Dolan it has make a great
game but it's not everything you'll
grant me that right it's not everybody I
saw a guy who is screaming it some
people go back to Auschwitz you see some
people go back to Africa I mean but yes
everyone else the meteor is
cherry-picked a few from this side
versus a few from outside this is not
this is not you know this is I'm just
saying it's not it's not everybody I'm
not giving the media any great leisure
no fight well I mean okay there I'm sure
there are some supporters of Trump who
are
you know who are distasteful people like
there are supporters of Hillary sure I
think pretty much anyone who supports
her that's tasteful you know I think
pretty much anyone support Sanders this
just needs to need to read a book you
know there's needs to be educator needs
to these two which puberty I don't know
but the thing is about Trump supporters
in my experience vast majority of them
whether they fall into you know the
various buckets of Trump supporter you
know whether it's the huge support he
has in the black community for all sorts
of obvious reasons because he's a very
aspirational you know American dream
kind of candidate my colleague at bribe
our Sonny Johnson you know she's sister
said I love him I love him because when
I see Trump these guys name on the
building and he's got a name on a plane
I want that you know I was like a bling
element to it yeah it's not well it's
not just that some people are offended
by that kind of generalization but um oh
five there I said something that I
thought you'd be oh my god he said bling
and now no no that was a bit much no I
mean maybe that's one thing like me uh
no I am you know what I mean is you know
that he's a very classic aspirational
candidate for for black Americans also
loved by the gay community huge gay icon
there's a piece coming out in Mike I
think and another in vice soon I've
given interviews for both of these
places on why so many gay people love
Trump I think is obvious but you know
all that but the two big groups which
are kind of like well-educated yet what
I call generation from the internet Roly
some alrighty cultural libertarian sort
of Trump supporters who by and large are
the best people in the office so funny
and interesting and smart and brilliant
and I love them and the other group
which are also that you know the the
some of the best people in the world you
know the white working-class yeah who
are you know who are rightly worried
about the direction the company that the
country is taking the company C soon
it'll be a country that was the Freudian
looking for you got me you know I took
an hour but you got ya see fascism comes
with a smile bleach blonde hair yeah I'm
gonna start calling it the firm the we
got to fix the phone basically you're
saying that these two groups the clean
coals role family the foam I think any
one Jesse so these two groups coming
together it will just have it look I
feel
great joyful wonderful people and I love
them and they're there both of these
groups of my natural constituency both
of these groups are my readers of my
viewers both of these groups I think
hold with them united under under daddy
the promise of a better America I mean
so say that with no hint of exaggeration
I think these you know these groups
think about the gamergate you know
saying when when video game players the
least likely kind of group in the in the
world to rise up and beat the feminists
and they did beat the feminists they
were like really these like you know
anyone was thinking these you know
parents basement guys and video gamers
really and they won they did what no but
none of the rest of us had done well
they woke this thing I they won't do it
I did not know that this was happening
games is a direct sort of tributaries
and we mullet in the review yeah it's
inter intergeneration Trump you know and
and they work people up to the fact that
if you term as a progressive left and
you say I'm not sexist go [ __ ] yourself
nothing bad happens and in fact other
people around you start to notice and
they start to do it too
and these two groups together white
working-class you know ordinary people
who are seeing wages depressed and
worried about where their country is
going and that very high and a sort of
highly educated college student and into
they're up to about 35 kind of cross
like Gen X millennial borderline people
our age who are sick of having been told
what to do for 10 years by the aggressor
regressive left this Union of people the
the what I call generation Trump is some
is the most exciting cultural force that
has been in this country for decades and
it's it's a group of people that I'm
very proud to be part of them to have a
role in because I think they're great
and I think I think many of these people
whether it's the gamers in that top end
or the you know people they're just
people they just drive drive trucks for
a living whatever these are some of the
people who have been lied to and lied
about the most in American society for
decades and they're sick of it and
they're right to be sick of it and if
they can drive into the White House a
candidate like Trump who is going to you
know build a wall he's going to fix
trade he's going to do these things and
then if he doesn't do too much else
that's not such a disaster
a candidate like Trump who is going to
give the present establishment
journalists and politicians alike the
most colossal bloody nose and they
deserve it they have it coming you know
they won't really deserve this yeah then
I am fully behind it yeah and ironically
I think at that point you could make a
strong case that if Bernie does not get
the Democratic nomination that he should
actually a good portion of his people
should actually go to Trump because that
knows whether you agree with Bernie or
not and they go Hillary's obviously
going to get the nomination but the good
thing about trial a good thing that one
of the things about Sanders and Trump
supporters is a relatively politically
promiscuous that they want is to hurt
the bad guys and the bad guys now are
the New York Times you know the the
political class the banks whatever you
know all the all these people that that
you know controlling the rest of us and
knowing our own it not in our interests
I think many of them will come over and
I think you'll be surprised just how
many come over because their concerns
aren't that different and when you look
at if you look at like the Sanders
rallies and look at the Trump rallies
there's a similar sort of there's a sort
of fun young exciting kind of atmosphere
in both the crowds they have a very
similar feel to them the atmosphere of
those events is in many ways very
similar and I think people are more
interested in the sort of cultural ties
across political lines these days than
they are with you know Republican and
Democrat levels right so those cultural
ties that's really what brought us
together so I guess to wrap all this
thing up is that the the left that
portion of the left that you would argue
is probably 90% of the left if not 100
percent plus me and one other guy but
that will leave yeah so all right so you
got million libertarian before so
between yeah well I this point I would
basically say I'm a classic liberal to
libertarian somewhere in there which
actually believe it or not people don't
like to hear it but it's actually on the
conservative side and look I mean with
the Liberals watching this you did this
to him I mean you know you've you forced
him in you force leftist perfectly nice
you know domesticated liberal gay man
into talking about free speech on the
Internet you know crazy what happen
here but if they did something good
between the regressive left and the
authoritarians that between the power
structure the media the politicians all
that they did wake this thing up and
that's why me and you can sit here and
do this and still have a drink after and
agree and disagree in whatever and you
did a good cell job you didn't bring me
all the way but you but you lay out an
interesting case and that's what I'm
interested in hearing yeah you know and
so they did do something because they
all of the people that are in this mix
now that we talk about all the time you
know from Rogan and christina hoff
sommers and you know sam Harris and
Majid and all of these people all over
the map have woken up so that to me is
the the takeaway that I can feel good
about with this regardless of who
becomes president regardless of the
political end of this well is that we're
here and we're doing this and that's
what that's what the authoritarians on
either side fear the most correct and
it's and I think it's inexorable I think
it is irresistible if you look at the
1990s the emergence of political
correctness in the 1990s which was
beaten back very successfully by a
coalition like us well we are the ones
doing it now and although in the 90s
these people as Christina likes to say
got the assistant professorship sand you
know stayed in tenure in the
universities and all the rest of it
had to go away from the media but never
really went away they just sort of you
know consolidated their power and
returned as social justice warriors this
time there's so much more on the line
for them because if they break this time
they are breaking they are losing with
the full support of politicians the
media and academia and if if people rise
up now and say this social justice thing
is language policing this political
correctness safe spaces trigger warnings
microaggressions this stuff is horseshit
and if enough people smash it
stranglehold on the public square it
will never recover it will never get
never come back in like this again
because it will lose at the height of
its powers it will lose in its strongest
possible form it will lose as we say in
you know the Internet in its final form
social justice cannot get any stronger
than it is now it is it is at it at the
peak of its powers and it's losing so
and it's losing because people want
freedom they want to be able to do say
think be play and read anything and they
have the faith in themselves and in
other people that they and are able to
make the best judgments for themselves
on what they believe in they don't need
to be told how to speak they don't need
to be told which books to read they
don't need to be told which videogames
are dangerous they don't need to be told
any of these things they don't need to
be instructed and lecture to by
politicians they don't need to be
badgered and hectored by feminists and
they don't need to be lied to by
journalists and people are sick of it
and they are sick of the entire
mendacious edifice and this is what was
happening so wonderfully right now with
people like us and all the other
conversations that are happening in
cultural libertarian movement and in
general what I call generation Trump and
Daddy and all this kind of stuff the fun
mischievous trolli element on the
internet what is behind all of this the
the heart of all of this is that
rejection that fundamental rejection of
the idea that somebody else knows better
than I do how I should live my life man
you know how to give a closing argument
I was really good right no cue cards
over there at all the hands of
professionals here for the record I did
not look at these once I had a lot of
questions for you but I think we did a
fine job here so of course I want to
thank Molly and Ovilus for joining me
thank you guys can check out all his
enough at at Breitbart com follow him on
Twitter it's at Nero there are roughly
how many how many copies of you do well
I think I'm the most imitators
personally Internet yeah they created
all the rocks it's created a gremlin in
water that's here with you how myriad
don't feed him after midnight uh I don't
know but if you look NER Oh like the
Emperor who was awesome except for the
Christian burning everything I was great
nobody's perfect when I was good you
know he was he was I mean it was an
egotist fine I'll take that you know he
was self-involved as fine he was spent
too much money on himself and he raised
half of Rome my view a gigantic Palace
called the Domus Aurea when he finally
moved into the parrot into the palace I
think is what I thinks it was in
Suetonius I think he said um finally I
can start live as human beings that's
not yeah he was hated by the elites the
Senate hated him but loved by the people
so I'm it was a good it was probably the
best of so you want to turn this country
Emperor into a company and you want your
palace
oh I missed nobody who wouldn't want to
live in neuropathies there's no blue
check but just take my word for it
Thanks we'll do it again next week